[Music]
Chak Eck rose from the underworld to the
surface of the eastern sea and on into
the heavens his brother clean a howl
followed though chuck had arisen first
beam a howl out shown him and the
resentful Chuck Eck descended back to
the underworld to plot against his
brother in Mayan mythology chuck ik
represents venus and keen a howl
represents the Sun known as both the
morning and the evening star Venus moves
to the sky sometimes visible before
sunrise
sometimes after sunset and occasionally
not at all the ancient Maya identified
this roughly 584 day cycle more than a
thousand years ago and it still
accurately predicts when and where Venus
will appear in the sky around the world
five of these cycles make up almost
exactly eight years and the Maya also
recognize this larger cycle they assign
chalk egg five different forms one for
each cycle of Venus that were repeated
every eight years within the 584 day
cycle Venus is visible in the evening
sky for 250 days then disappears for
eight days before reappearing as a
morning star the ancient Maya ascribed
particular significance to this point in
the cycle the first time Venus appears
before sunrise after being invisible
on this day Chuck a clue is again from
the underworld wielding a spear thrower
and darts to bring discord to the world
he decided to
his brother and his brothers allies his
first target was cogwheel god of
sustenance and lightning rising in the
late rainy season Chuck Eck aimed his
spear and struck Kali causing damage to
the food and a period of chaos in the
social order until cop wheel was reborn
584 days after attacking wheel
chock egg turned his attention back to
his brother the Sun each night the Sun
took the form of Jaguar and journey
through the underworld chuck XP r DJ
guar son as it rose at dawn towards the
end of the dry season the son was
wounded plunging the world into a period
of chaos and warfare shock ex third
victim was the god of maize who provided
sustenance for all humankind shock
experiment I'm of the harvest he was
buried in the underworld and may as the
staple of water was no longer available
to Earth's inhabitants but the maize God
emerged after three months in the place
of new beginnings the eastern cave known
as seven water place burning food once
again
when the turtle och Ngoc rose in the sky
to mark the summer solstice chalk
exclaimed his fourth victim with the
death of this good omen the Sun the food
supply and the people were buried within
the earth and the forces of chaos
reigned but out of the chaos rose a new
order established by whom
aha one of the hero twins known to all
for having vanquished the lords of the
underworld a new race of humans was
created made from maize this state of
balance was not to last however chalk X
fifth and final victim was a mysterious
stranger from the West and his death in
the heart of the dry season shook the
order established by human aha
the gods the lords and the maids were
buried in the underworld
but this victory for chalk egg would
also prove temporary the two brothers
Venus and the Sun were caught in an
endless cycle as they battled for
supremacy
reenacting the same five struggles while
the world alternated between order and
chaos with the rising of the morning
star want more myths follow Hercules and
eight bits as he atoned for the death of
his family or dive into Irish mythology
and travel with ocean to the land of
eternal youth
[Music]